Video minut
Games
okay
[Music]
indan
4 E5
[Music]
D5 basic
forg
okay
ja [
Music]
so
B
longling ja
mays4 [
Music]
das
G4
H4 he can try to set up a dark Square
blockade of
course not with
C6 meant something like  Bishop
E7 maybe H6 H7 Bishop
E7 passive Plan musm
okay G4
G5 C5
coming
okay
got the good
Pie C5 now D6 interesting yes very [
Music]
interesting
don't really quick attack
h C4 of course
hanging yes
B3
[Music]
C not
[Music  ]
exactly
yes looks good
black Prob my plan was B please
Cre
maybe B3
coming
night B3 ver play King
B1
Bad
okay
B3
king1
D22
black no
that
covering at
least get structure
damaged
that's really
ugly maybe irritate
[Music]
Mo
yes  now not
great okay Check out try to complicate
Mats
here
C4 at
least
complicated Prob takes D5
C5
C4 may not 100%
clear h
doing good
job
join play
quicklyen3 [
Music]
here [
[Music]
JA5
okay maybe not so
[Music]
terrible provoke
Exchange strong
Bishop
yes very low on
time need to be quick
now Position such great problem anymore
good
now
no
[Music]
time great
job
try [
Music]
get
yes okay
das B me not
B h
[Music]
black
[  Music]
[Music]
engl answer
to kind
of
Setup play E4 pretty much regardless
doing interesting knows it
ofour bnoying
for
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
B4
F4
mes
[Music]
c55ous F4 OP
King
[Music]
more
yes
solided
jau B4 maybe can play B5 himself may
possible yes the setup with taking on4
and C5 is really annoying for
white yes
actually play
B5 okay h [
Music]
slighten
may
[Music]
F3
ofing
okay
okay yes he  WS go
no
[Music]
F3 may
point we G3 of our
got
Plan
h45 try get
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
B7
[Music]
en
doing
and now play A5 could simply take
it
yes
block of
Queen
Bling yes
continue
yes
not let
sort
Flex
F2
B h bish
H3 maybe play B
F2 s H4
bish
may the king
H4 very complicated
Position
[Music]
okay okay [Music]
stay
Prot [Music
] [
Music]
den
okay now nothing nothing
[Music]
[Music  ]
H
Check okay so
covered don't any ttics see at
least
yes
Prob very very
stupid
yes
okay [
Music]
d
cannot move the PAS was the
idea
Earth playing so good Moves Absol Zero
time
theock try
win
mistake los time yes
Sound
not
[  Music]
finish
[Music
] [Music] [
Music]
Compu yes okay very very little
time
Game
minute
yes
[Music]
cra6 [
Music]
betters
try Block
King
[Music]
Mayes
solid devel
[Music]
pieces
F5
yes
[Music]
the play5  bish6 Queen
B6 yes okay
[Music]
take
press
G5
take
[Music]
so G8
interesting
G3
yes
complicatedide was play here Queen A6
Bishop D3 D3 E4
maybe yes
elabor
[Music]
interesting A7 Prob
A7 cing
C5
not
sound
[Music]
video yes yes
so
B7 G5
Prob
W
G5
interesting yes let let Exchange
all try to enter with the Queen put the
bishop
on4 okay really [
Music]
WSS get
in yes
kingck first thing attacking
C3 what exactly playing
now Queen Exchange take
D4 A4 weakness
yes Prob
[Music  ]
kingen
yes
die
promote simply doesn't anything to
attack okay
Check
yes
okay
aha [
Music]
tak [
interesting yes [
Music]
die
Prob
here sort ofuring
KS need go King
G2 now let's
just march with the
PA
okay yes Prob
A2
[Music]
B3
yes Bishop
E3 ​​UPS a
Check
ces
not possible to spoil
this yes okay where does this piece go
now there
C
takes
promote a Bishop A1
here
bish2
prom
take l i yes
K here right don't tell me
Defense night5
night2  next
[Music]
move
to get get Queen
notce may
[Music]
disconnected
ja ja
okay pretty pry
clean [
Music]
Computer
[Music]
ut
thanksing back
[Music]
videingover new
part
Video yes
by